Before we turn to finding
a faster algorithm for
finding a maximum matching,
there's a classic theorem related to
matchings that we should talk about.
This is the Frobenius-Hall theorem.
For a subset of vertices,
say x, we'll use n of x to
indicate the union of the neighbors
of the individual vertices in x.
If we consider this graph here then the
neighbors of the orange vertices will be
the green ones.
Note that the fact
that if we call this x,
then the size of the neighborhood
of x is larger than x.
That this bodes well for the possibility
of finding a matching for
all the vertices on
the left hand side here.
At least, there's a chance that we
will be able to find a match for
all these vertices.
When this is not the case however,
as seen for
these three vertices here,
then it is hopeless.
Regardless of how we
matched the first two,
there will be no remaining
candidates for the third vertex.
We can make this intuition precise
with the Frobenius-Hall theorem,
which follows from the max matching
min vertex cover argument.
Given a bipartite graph G partitioned
into L and R, there exists
a matching of size L if and only if for
every X with is a subset of L,
the size of the neighborhood of
X is at least the size of X.
The forward direction
is the simpler one.
Let M be a matching of size L, and we'll
let x be a subset of the left hand side.
We let y be the vertices on the right
hand side that x got matched to.
Clearly, y is the same size as x, but
then y is also a subset of
the neighborhood of x, and hence,
the size of the neighborhood of
x Is at least the size of X.
The other direction is
a little more challenging.
Suppose not.
We'll let M be a max matching,
with cardinality strictly less than
the cardinality of the left-hand side.
We let H be the set of vertices
reachable from an alternating path
from the unmatched vertices in L.
This is the same picture
used in the max, matching,
min vertex cover argument.
There's at least one unmatched
vertex here by our assumption.
Well then the neighborhood
of the left hand side of H
is equal to the right hand side of H.
But this left hand side must be strictly
greater because there's at least
one unmatched vertex.
If you like,
you can think about the matched vertices
on either side canceling each other out.
And we're left with some non-0 number
of unmatched vertices
on the left hand side.